a few months ago I asked the question
how evil can you be in Hogwarts Legacy
after the most recent gameplay showcase
I think we have our answer
the new gameplay footage of Hogwarts
Legacy showed off a combat-centric horde
mode area known as the dark arts battle
arena and they wasted no time in showing
off all three unforgivable spells and
just how Sinister they can be now back
when we knew very little about Hogwarts
Legacy one of the biggest fan requests
was without a doubt please include the
unforgivable curses in the game to be
honest I personally had my doubts they
would be included at all and then even
after abbotta Kadabra was confirmed with
the first gameplay reveal many again
including myself felt it would only be
used as one of the game's special
finisher spells and not as a slottable
spell that you can just have on you at
any time but this showcase revealed the
three unforgivables will all be
available as slottable spells to the
player we'll start with imperio here
which was confirmed in an official post
back on Halloween we got a description
at that time of how it would work in
battle however this recent showcase
marks the first time we've seen it in
action it will essentially turn an enemy
into an ally on the battlefield and
they'll fight alongside you so while the
Imperial spell may be unique to the
Potter series this type of gameplay
effect is something that will be
familiar to many players where things
get interesting is that Imperial will
also place a cursed status effect on
anyone who gets hit with the spell so
take note of this little green x that
you see here this is also true of crucio
so in addition to their normal effects
they'll also cause enemies to become
cursed it remains to be seen if there
are other curse inducing spells in the
game or if it's just these two but this
enables an incredibly deadly combo of
creating a situation where multiple
enemies actually share damage that's
right any enemy with this curse effect
placed upon them will all take the same
damage so we don't know the full limits
of this yet but theoretically I mean you
could have a situation where multiple
enemies are surrounding you you hit them
all with this curse effect and then you
cast Avada Kedavra on one of them and
they all fall at the same time my
goodness Voldemort would be so proud of
you guys right now
believe it or not AK is a true
insta-death spell in Hogwarts Legacy
game director Alan 2 said it was very
very important for the team that this
spell be true to the series so we
actually see it throughout this recent
gameplay take down a full health
mountain troll human Wizards goblins all
of varying Health levels of course with
such a powerful spell balance is
obviously a concern which the dev team
is addressing by a longer cooldown meter
for spells like Avada Kedavra even so
there are potions in the game and
presumably even more upgrades along the
way that will enable us to speed up
these cooldowns now you want to know
something crazy guys Avada cadaver it's
not even the darkest spell in this game
no no no that is reserved for the
torture curse crucio of the three this
was the one I often doubted they would
ever even include I mean the spell quite
literally exists to torture other living
beings in fact one of the most tragic
moments in the entire Potter series of
course is when the trio saw what became
of Neville's parents Frank and Alice
Longbottom after they were tortured with
the cruciatus curse so in the game it
exists as a spell to essentially
incapacitate enemies on the battlefield
take them out of the battle it also
appears to have a slight damage over
time effect as well well but I think the
most Sinister the most dark part about
all of this with crucio is the sound
effect I mean this little effect alone
just when you cast the spell sounds
absolutely terrifying just like Souls
crying out
[Music]
and then you can even hear the enemies
on the battlefield crying out in pain I
mean it's absolutely brutal
now earlier in the video you remember I
mentioned how we originally thought that
AK would be a finisher spell well we
actually gotta look at some of those as
well and guys they are equally as deadly
for one we have a finisher that seems to
be possible when this meter reaches the
halfway point and it just completely
obliterates this enemy I mean it seems
like this guy just combusts in midair
before our very eyes and then another
similar one here but you see it has a
slightly different visual effect and
then maybe for a more I don't know
humorous one this one's still kind of
dark too but we have another finisher
spell that actually transfigures enemies
into a chicken and then of course we
can't forget the massive Lightning Spell
that we've already seen in a previous
trailer now what's interesting about
this whole dark arts battle arena is
that you can try this area out even if
you don't want to learn dark magic so
let's say you're like me you know we're
the good Gryffindor we're doing a
playthrough as a purely good no dark
magic character you can still go into
the dark arts battle arena to get a
little taste of what it would be like
and they actually confirmed there are
going to be three of these Arenas in the
game with the dark arts Arena only be
included in the deluxe Edition or as
part of the dark arts pack which buyers
of the standard edition can purchase as
an add-on now even though I'm not really
a dark magic kind of guy what I love is
the moral dilemmas that they're already
setting up here in a previous trailer we
learned that Sebastian sallow is the one
who introduces us to crucio the torture
curse and what's interesting about what
Sebastian is doing this is actually one
of the few story details that we know is
that he is trying to find a cure for his
sister who has some sort of curse we
don't really know what it is yet we've
speculated but we don't know for sure
and he believes that dark magic may
somehow be the path to being able to
cure her we even hear him say at one
point that an unforgivable spell should
not be unforgivable if it can save a
life and then also what about those of
us on the side of the light the no dark
magic playthrough kind of folks well
Alan unfortunately did not go into
specifics but he did mention this there
are dark eyes fantasies there's
fantasies about being more of a defense
against the dark arts character things
like that that Misty step that you see
um occasionally being used on the
battlefield and we can also back into
our potions and plants to make them more
powerful and more efficacious so it's
all about which type of player you feel
like you are and whether or not you want
to play with prep on the fly or with
deliberation and those are all different
options so there is still hope my
friends maybe stealth maybe more
maneuver type mechanics and I've still
got my fingers crossed for expecto
patronum as well the gameplay showcase
also gave us a look at the open world
exploration as well as a stunning look
at all the customization options in the
room of requirement as well as these
vivariums where we're going to be able
to care and nurture magical beasts I've
already posted my full reaction video to
the entire showcase which I'll
conveniently link here on the right side
of your screen now as always plenty more
Hogwarts Lexi videos coming folks thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon